it looks like you can find it anywhere
so it's like because you you eat
whatever well i'm probably probably on
man vs wild and over the years i've
become more of a scavenger really you
know it's always kind of finding
you know rotten carcasses or whatever
which is more the reality of the wild as
trying to hunt down big food is is super
energy consuming time consuming high
risk as well so really traditionally is
why we were always hunter-gatherers you
know you were unless you were working as
a team and you became very efficient at
hunting which we did as humankind but
really as a survivor you're you're
conserving energy you're minimizing risk
and you're going for the the grubs and
the berries and the roots and and being
smart and not eating things that can
either kill you or make you sick which
of course has happened to me many times
when did your stomach left you down well
the stomach this well so food choices
let me down you know i remember eating
one particularly
dodgy snake that i found and um
and i should have known it was bad
because it was stinking but
anyway it was it was dead it was well
actually i killed it i'd eaten half and
i had kept the rest of it and a day
later was smelling pretty bad but i ate
it and i remember
he was saying i can't try and think
where it was i think it was in namibia
and i was halfway up this rock face
and uh and i said to the camera i felt
the diarrhea coming you know you know
what i wouldn't
i don't you know
you just tummy rumbling it's not bad you
know so you all know what it's like but
you also know when that happens you're
on the time clock you know and i said to
the camera i said turn the camera off
this isn't gonna wait to the top i'm not
gonna make it to the top in time yeah
and so he was kind of way you are a bit
further away and i hung on with one hand
and used the other hand to get my
trousers down
and then um
i don't know what time the show goes out
on camera when i did the diary into free
air and there was a camera at the bottom
he was like
but anyway
something was filming
i thought they weren't filming at the
end of it i pulled my trailer i thought
job done
and looked there and there was a sort of
red blinking light on camera there's
nothing sacred you know
so um
but you know that was that's been a big
part of the show big part of the
adventures the mistakes as well as the
i mean really it's what i've tried to
write about in this book is the failures
and the mistakes and the struggles and
the times it goes wrong because
that's life isn't it you know that's how
we learn and grow and
get better the book is called never give
up and i i wonder
uh
talking about food did you ever taste
something that tastes so bad that you
had to give up you you had to just blah
i can't eat that
yeah actually watching that little vt
that little clip that that beetle i was
very wrong about because it was actually
a sting beetle and i was quite confident
going it's not going to taste nice but
it's great here we go and it was just an
explosion of like super kind of powerful
acid that has squirted in my mind i
thought instantly is like reaction like
this isn't just bad this is wrong
get it out
but most of the time i'm i'm
vaguely confident in what i'm doing and
i kind of think yeah that's that's
pretty good but um
yeah sometimes nobody ever comes around
for dinner
i don't have to worry about calories
hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations please hit
subscribe